hawaii is suing president Trump over his
latest travel ban in response President
Trump is suing Hawaii for being hard to
spell
[Applause]
it's hard to get my hair to go down like
trumps right right mine just wants to
reach to the gods you know his gave up a
long time ago Walt Disney Studios in the
news Disney has announced that its
upcoming live-action Aladdin movie is
going to feature Middle Eastern actors
good filming will begin in May or
whenever the actors are no longer
detained at the airport just report it
there Oh some people don't like that so
much it's hard to laugh in that
situation people are really being
detained you know I'm making it worse
now by I really it is a serious matter
apologies all around that took care of
it
new research came out this is a
fascinating story I saw this in the
paper today new research says that
Neanderthals used to relieve pain by
chewing on a plant containing the main
ingredient in aspirin that's what the
inner cells did yes or is that's now
being called the Republican health care
plan
well I like that better than the
prettiest for the second time ladies and
gentlemen RadioShack has filed for
bankruptcy second time experts say if
RadioShack goes bankrupt one more time
it can officially run for president I
just won't do it it's won't do it this
is fascinating many years many years
after dropping out of Harvard Facebook
founder Mark Zuckerberg is going back to
get an honorary degree yeah yeah
Zuckerberg said he would have gone back
sooner but even he can't afford college
these days
[Applause]
you gave me plenty that was fine that
was more than I need in Italy this is
fascinating in Italy there are now
allegations of orgies prostitution and
porn involving Catholic priests Wow I
need to start going to church again get
back there you've been there in a while
it sounds fantastic
you